good morning believe nation today's
message is take your shot over to you
Kevin Smith I go into the emergency room
and I was like Donald Smith and like I'm
sorry he passed they took me into the
room was my father laying on a gurney
just dead still has a tube sticking out
of him and they're trying to intubate
him or something like that but just
motionless quiet no breathing whatsoever
and it was weird news it mean to say the
least she always know eventually parents
going to go but I wasn't ready I wasn't
ready for that good moment and then I
walked out and I went outside not a
cigarette I still cigarette smoker in
those days and I was just thinking about
being half an orphan or halfway to being
an orphan or something like that my
brother comes out and I was like oh I
can't believe it right he goes yeah it's
pretty tough and I said how was it
because my brother was there he was
staying with my fault my parents and
Donald without missing a beat my brother
goes dad died screaming and I was like
what and he goes dad died screaming has
what he mean like well he woke up and he
was kicking the sheets off and screaming
about being on fire and he was so hot
and so hot and get him water and [ __ ]
screaming the screaming got louder and
louder and it reached a fever pitch and
he died and I don't know how else to say
it but Dad died screaming and that hit
me like a Mack truck and I remember
thinking oh my god in this world or even
a good man like my old man is going to
die screaming there's no point and not
trying to achieve every dream that i
have this is my eventual end one day
that's this
and and I really felt like man that's
like it I can't this is my future we're
all probably going to go out screaming
so the best thing to do prior to that is
to try to pack that life with as much
wonderfulness fun productivity surround
yourself with people that are going to
help you do that you know gives in this
world there's not a lot of support a lot
of negativity is a lot of [ __ ]
sentences and even as I sit here and
tell that story about my father dying I
guarantee there's a cynical head in this
house maybe more sitting there going who
cares move on tell a dick joke the world
is full of why man you tell people
something they'll tell you why throw
rock and you'll hit somebody with y lo
que me I want to make a movie why why do
you think you could do that why why
nobody else is doing it why are you
doing it there's so much why you go out
and you find why not you surround
yourself with why not people are just
like why not we're lucky man I'm gonna
try something like I why not let's give
it a shot people will try to help you do
your dreams make your dreams come true
and shouldn't you do the same for
remember all in this together and it
costs nothing to encourage an artist
that's why I get up here for almost 20
years now after the movie man a lot of
filmmakers get up after the movie and
spend more time than the movie itself
talking but I've been trying to impart
one simple lesson for nearly 20 years
anybody can do this you know what I'm
saying like I wasn't born into a
business or the film business or born
with a mic in my hand I have no
discernible talent whatsoever man I have
no connections to the business we're
from New Jersey and stuff I got lucky
somebody picked up the movie and boom I
was off and running and part of that
manifest when you're in brought into the
indie film community part of your your
job part of your honor part of your
privilege is to make sure that keeps
going to encourage other people you know
to tell people it's worth the shot just
like Wayne Gretzky said like you miss a
hundred percent of the shots you never
take it's always worth a shot now if
you're talking about legacy if what your
shot is just like I've always wanted to
kill 12 children Kevin don't take that
shot at all
I'm not talking about that you know I'm
talking about Archie [ __ ] you know right
in the blog making some music making a
movie making a cupcake store the
knitting store putting together of the
YouTube clip just anything that's just
not oh we must do this because it's part
of my job or this will get money some
[ __ ] you just do just to see if it could
be done live a why not life man because
we're all going to die screaming so make
sure when you die screaming you're
totally fulfilled you like I took all
the shots i did it i went after
everything i wanted to or at least tried
take the shot the shot is always worth
taking whether it's a dopey thing like
podcasting or writing a book or writing
a blog think about the encouragement you
get when you encouraging artists think
about the potential that comes out of it
you tell it dude good job man that
person maybe one day writes that blog
that you meme out to the entire world
because it says exactly what you always
want to say but couldn't yourself or
they write that song that you play over
and over after a loved one dies because
it means the world to you that they make
that movie that is the one you cling to
when everything is going wrong in life
all you pop that in and things aren't
bad for two hours all that comes from
encouraging an artist nothing good comes
from discouraging an artist so for 20
years I keep coming up here and going go
out and do it why the [ __ ] aren't you
doing this it's so fun you should do it
take your shot I took my shot and it's
nothing but [ __ ] and donut you know so
I'm here to tell you man give it a shot
go out and try thank you guys so much
for watching the question of the day
today is what was the biggest shot that
you have taken leave eight in the
comments below I'm going to join in the
discussion I also want to give a quick
shout atisha shear shenoy from shenoy
international thank you so much so much
so much for buying a copy of my book
your one word it really really really
means a lot to me thank you guys again
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is let's love and
we'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of inspect Oh
preto give me go